even before announcing the inquiry the
government preemptively defended its
decision invoking the emergencies act
was a decision that was taken only after
careful consideration
the public inquiry will be given powers
to summon witnesses under oath and force
them to provide necessary documents it
will examine circumstances that led to
the convoy protests which gridlocked
downtown ottawa for weeks and choked off
traffic at canada u.s border crossings
and it will explore a key question was
the emergencies act a government
overreaction or necessary to restore
order in the nation's capital the act is
only to be used in the event of a
national emergency the act defines a
national emergency as an urgent
temporary and critical situation that
seriously endangers the health and
safety of canadians or seriously
threatens the government's ability to
preserve the sovereignty security and
territorial integrity of canada we are
talking about a very high threshold
whether it's you know espionage violent
extremism
or subversion or
you know other kind of very major
serious threats protest organizers say
the government overreached
at no time
did this convoy in ottawa
meet those standards it was a completely
inappropriate use the government insists
the danger and the damage went far
beyond ottawa the incredible
and devastating damage that was done to
public safety at ports of entry
in the form of interruption to
trade and travel the interruption to
supply chains the inquiry commissioner
is paul rulo he's spent 20 years as a
judge in ontario in a statement rulo
says i am committed to ensuring the
process is as open and transparent as
possible but it's unclear if the
government will release cabinet
documents related to its decision mr
speaker that inquiry will be useless
unless they waive cabinet confidence and
allow canadians to know the whole story
the government insists rulo will have
broad powers and access the ability to
compel witnesses and the compel the
production of documents subject as
always to lawful
privileges of evidence that may exist
bruno has until next february to report
his findings
ross lord global news